okay now that we've talked through a few
examples of goals and metrics to track
let's go through a few scenarios
together I want you to match the
following goals with the best metric
options you see below by writing the
corresponding letter and the boxes
you'll see first for learn to fly calm
your goal is to increase qualified
traffic to your website for your flight
school business by 10% each month for
six months and we want to increase
traffic to be from people who can
actually afford flying lessons and who
have time to devote to flying lessons
okay now for the second scenario movie
mancom you have a video streaming
service and you notice that 30% of the
people are dropping off after the first
month your goal is to decrease drop off
by 20% over the next four months your
metric options are a traffic increase be
retention rate see conversions D signups
fill in the boxes with the corresponding
letters